there's something which has been called
the dowel of the ancestors what that
means I think is simply that for each
one of us there is a way to do the
things we must do that is the most
energy-efficient way to do it and I'm
talking about opening a door picking up
a fork the best way to do it is to
follow the kre-o that is the dowel of
the ancestors to recognize that you are
a genetic expression of partial genetic
expression of a gene pool which has
received genetic expression at each
generation in your family for thousands
and thousands of generations and that
you are just the latest resection
reception of this gene pool then you
release the ego and you act with this
awareness
these are psychedelically induce states
of being that I can make it easier to
live in the world and how many of them
are there who knows for instance under
the influence of psilocybin in the
Amazon I noticed what I am completely
convinced is an atrophied human ability
it's a very simple ability but we have
lost it it's the ability to know how to
walk from point A to point B not
following the shortest distance but
following automatically the the path of
least resistance so that you don't go
down into valleys and then climb hill
you automatically stay on ridges even
though you take more circuitous paths to
your goal and I could feel this sense
working it was just like a part of the
dashboard that had previously been
covered up was uncovered here was a
human sense which we don't particularly
need because we've erected linear cities
where they must the path of least
resistance usually is a straight line
but you can imagine people in rugged
country this is a sense which would
confer great survival adaptability be
tremendously important
you